[Music]
love that music super bowl
55 the double nickel will not look like
any other super bowl because of the
pandemic it's going to take place at
raymond james stadium in tampa florida
they'll play host to sunday's big game
between the chiefs and the buccaneers
but because of covid the stadium will be
more than half
empty jamie yukas is in tampa right now
to show us how the nfl
is getting creative to make the stadium
look full even though it's not jamie
good morning to you no snow where you
are
yeah good morning tony with only six
days to go between now and game day
organizers are hitting the final stretch
and as you mentioned we will see only
about 22
000 fans inside come sunday which is
nearly a
third of its capacity including roughly
7 500
vaccinated healthcare workers but
playing inside a half empty stadium
was not going to be an option so the nfl
went looking for a solution
five ten years ago this print right now
would take us about an hour to print
but with these speeds and these new
lights takes about 45 seconds
jared smith has been in the printing
business for more than 20 years
his tempe arizona company blue media and
their hundred
and twenty thousand square foot factory
was tapped by the nfl
to help with a super bowl size problem
the league had a challenge of do we fill
the stadium with cutouts do we play in a
half empty stadium
what is socially responsible as far as
the amount of fans that we can allow
the answer a bit of both alongside the
tens of thousands of real fans who will
be socially distanced
inside raymond james stadium will be
these plastic recyclable
cardboard like cutouts submitted from
football fans
around the world they're all created
here in arizona
and all part of the nfl's program called
fans in the stands
for a hundred bucks for cutout fans
uploaded their photos online
with all proceeds going to charity i
think we'll be producing between 20 and
30 000 cutouts for the super bowl by the
time it's all said and done
you know every single one of these
they're actual people and they're from
all over the country and it's cool to
see
almost everybody is smiling just the
concept that they're gonna get to be in
the game
just like their living counterparts the
cutouts started showing up in tampa this
past
weekend who's this first one look at
that oh minnesota viking matt burke
okay did you know i'm a viking fan i did
not know that
we opened it up to each segment jason
baker is the director of execution for
blue media
and is responsible for installation
we'll have
basically seven day install from now
till the sixth so all the way up till
saturday night
game times on the seventh and then we
tear it all out on the eighth
by this morning blue media tells us they
will have nearly half of their cutouts
already installed
and they're being specially grouped
including sections for military veterans
health care workers and cancer survivors
one of the cool stories once we
installed those
we saw 30 35 mile an hour winds and the
fan cutouts were moving a little bit at
first we were concerned
but when you stepped back it kind of
looked like the fans were cheering and
it was it was really cool
no one's liking the fact that we're in
the middle of a pandemic is this a
way to make it fun how do we
come together as a community both
celebrating fans and then honoring
heroes and this is a great way to do it
so we're excited to be a part of it
we made sure blue media put in a special
addition to their production order look
who's going to dance
i love it wow
never been thinner now is that a real
person
can i please have it after the super
bowl i will so take
care of it yeah i know that i don't know
i don't have one of those
that's a great joke i love it i've never
been to the super bowl
so yeah we've got a couple extra we'll
make sure we ship them to you thank you
please do we'll get them to you thank
you jamie i appreciate it
all right and you can watch super bowl
55 on sunday february 7th
right here on cbs he likes saying that